okay
hopefully people come in
here in the next little bit turn off our
video recording device what's up
shadow king what's happening dude
okay
shadow king you're the first one here
you know what shadow came because you're
the first one here
you get a rob core ring send me an email
what's up guys how's everybody doing
wanda vision let's talk about wanda
vision
you know originally i was going to make
a video and i was like you know what i'm
not going to make a video i'm just going
to talk to my fans about it let me just
do a live stream just talk to you guys
about one division right you guys like
live streams don't you
if you like live streams type type yes
type yes in the comments
if you like it when i do live streams
just type yes
and that works because i think i might
just do this whenever the episodes come
out and we'll just talk about like the
episodes and stuff
that'll be fun uh which i should
probably change the name of this but
i'll let people know ahead of time
um do we okay do we want to do spoilers
in this everybody's saying yes
[Laughter]
everybody's saying yes
uh no now you guys are just you guys are
saying no just to say no
but um oh not when you're in school
oh you guys are in school yeah i guess
you guys are in school aren't you it's
like
like 2 30. are you really in school
though what you're doing you're sitting
at home
watching this it's what you're probably
doing
not in school not being in school like
you're supposed to be
you know you're supposed to be in school
not in school uh
yeah so um
do you guys uh
do you guys like it when i massage your
ears with my voice
and i talk in a relaxing way
to caress those eardrums
that sounds so creepy all right if you
want to see spoilers type spoilers
just type spoilers like like telling you
guys the type stuff's like the easiest
way to figure out whether or not you
guys want to see something it's just the
easiest way
so if you want to see see spoilers type
spoilers
so that way i can get a feel for it
it's like creepy yes
[Laughter]
the voice of an angel
[Laughter]
oh man spoilers wow you guys are going
in on spoilers
okay
lots of people are typing spoilers uh
all right i guess this is a spoiler
episode
uh okay then what do you guys want to
know about the first two episodes
what do you guys want to know now here's
the thing here's the thing before we
start this this stream i do want to tell
you guys
um over on pop culture explained i have
a video coming out it's not there yet
it's not up yet
but i have a video coming out today that
basically reveals
pretty much where the show is going to
go because i think i know exactly how
this show's going to end
and and pretty much what everything
that's going on right
um so i'll reveal that on on pop culture
explained right that'll be on on that
youtube channel you actually find the
the youtube channel down in the
description
uh people seem to love it man like that
channel's blowing
up it is it's insane like we did stan
lee explained stanley and explain almost
has like 10 000 views
you guys love it man you guys are going
nuts on pop culture explain
i don't know how many of you guys are
part of that channel how many of you
guys are on pop culture
explained like if you're on pop culture
explain just
if you're on pop culture explain type
yes
i feel like it's just yes and spoilers
for the whole stream today
oh man but yeah if you guys are subbed
to pop culture explain just type yes
and if you're not then why aren't you
subscribed why are you not subscribed
i don't know i don't understand one
division is the best thing coming out of
dc rebirth absolutely elle fisher you
know what elle fisher because of that
comment
you get a rob core ring too send me an
email
send me an email you get a wrongful ring
um but yeah it's it's
so this is what this guy looks like yes
this is what i look like this is how i
look
technically it's kind of an off day it's
kind of a lazy day um
mariah's in cleveland visiting her
family and anybody who's married knows
like when the girl leaves that's when
the give-a-damn goes away man it's
nothing but sitting on the couch
scratching your balls watching tv and
playing video games that's all it is
like when i'm done here with the stream
i'm gonna go to a comic book store here
in town and i'm just gonna go buy some
comics come home reading
probably maybe order a pizza tonight and
just chill right have some pizza and
beer and that's that's gonna be it
that's that's my relaxing evening right
there
probably play spider-man miles morales
because that game is good that game is
so good
but like yeah man the devils are the
details dude that plot line
dude that line okay okay okay dude that
was an amazing line here's the thing
i don't think it means anything though i
don't think it means anything
maybe maybe it will i don't think it
means anything though it'd be cool if it
did
it'd be cool if it did right the devil's
in the details but i don't think i don't
think that actually means anything
i don't think it means mephisto
it'd be cool if it did but i don't think
it does
uh well i haven't really found an
official comic book store yet
i've been to one uh there's one in town
called or one right down the road called
capital city comics
which is cool i mean it's a cool story
to go into but i haven't found my comic
book store and funny enough we're
actually gonna be moving back to
back to colorado in um
let's see early to mid april maybe a
little bit closer to may but in april
sometime we're gonna move
um so i'm gonna be uh i'll be i'll be
out of here in columbus but for right
now i think for the the next
you know what is it month and a half two
and a half months
i'm gonna be here um i think i'll start
shopping at crazy comics because crazy
comics looks cool
so um but yeah okay so what do you guys
want to know what do you guys want to
know about
wandavision about the one division show
what do you guys want to know
the mephisto confirmed videos i'm gonna
freak if it turns out it's actually
mephisto i think mephisto is a little
too far-fetched
but but i'm i'm i'm i don't know
okay so so who do i think the villain is
um i think the villain is scarlet witch
i think scarlet witch is the main bad
guy in this story
i think she's the main bad guy here um
uh was the beekeeper doctor strange no
the beekeeper was probably somebody from
advanced idea mechanics
because they referred to themselves as
beekeepers and he was wearing the
advanced idea mechanics outfit the only
difference is that it wasn't yellow
right but he looks like somebody from
aim so he was most likely from advanced
idea mechanics
um yeah like liu kang already said it
yeah advanced idea mechanics
so uh the watch yeah struck her watch
he'll make time for you
that was so good that was so good have
you guys picked up on the fact that the
ads
are all the traumatic events that
scarlet witch has gone through have you
picked up on that yet
because that was cool like the bot the
tony stark bomb right like the tony
stark product
uh well technically it's a toaster but
the tony stark bomb that like killed her
family
and then the strucker watch have you
guys picked up on that yet because it
was that was cool
that was really really cool um
but yeah so uh you think she's in full
control yeah i think she is
i think she is too um
dottie the blonde no okay did you guys
notice something about dottie
did you notice something about dottie
right before the radio transmission
kicked in and jimmy wu
came in and said scarlet witch who's
doing this to you uh
did you guys pick up on dottie
did you guys pick up on that
yeah did you guys pick up on that at all
i hope you did
i wonder if you didn't deep
tahiti is a wonderful place
um yeah but advanced idea mechanics is
currently part of sword
or uh part of shield or at least what
used to be shield anyway
so um i don't think the beekeeper sword
or or it could be that advanced idea
mechanics is working for sword because
keep in mind
advanced idea mechanics contracts out
like we saw that during the events of
um during the no not imma frost
we saw that during the events of uh
jonathan hickman's avengers and new
avengers when robert decosta bought out
advanced idea mechanics
and and like they worked for uh for
basically shield
like we saw that in the comics so it's
not uncommon for for
advantage mechanics work for somebody
but i'm very sure he's
he's aim uh no um
donnie returned to normal for a second
right i
think like like here's here's what i
think here's what i think is going on
um i think that i think all those people
in that town are acting against their
will
because like there's a moment like the
radio transmission came in and all that
kind of stuff
and it took away scarlet which is
concentration right she lost her
concentration and if that's something
that you noticed that was something in
the old uh in the old avengers comics
right see it's the small things
it's the small things that make all the
difference so back in the day in the old
avengers comics
um when you had a vendor you had a
vision of scarlet witch and then you had
avengers west coast or west coast
avengers whatever you want to call it
that like scarlet witch's kids would
disappear right you guys remember i made
a video on that
that like i got the harness was
babysitting scarlet witch's kids and
then
uh and then scarlet witch would
basically like her kids would vanish
whenever scarlet witch lost her
concentration
and that's when agatha realized that
scarlet witch like her kids were not
actually there right
she they they weren't real tangible kids
they were constructs created by the
scarlet witch
and they ended up confronting her with
that then their kids went away and yeah
i think what's going on here
is that like this whole area is
constructed by scarlet witch it's
created by her
and that that she basically lost her
concentration when the radio
transmission came in
she was like wait like like what like
who in the world is doing that right it
was it was it was like what in the world
is going on and she lost her focus
and when she lost her focus dottie
returned back to normal and that's when
she's like who are you like she's like
what in the hell is all this and then
like as soon as scarlet which regained
her concentration dottie went right back
to who she was before right so
like i'm pretty sure that's that's
what's going on
so yeah well i don't know if i guess
it's not her neighbor
oh yeah yeah yeah agatha the uh the nosy
neighbor chick
yeah yeah um
beyond a mega level empty hand um
but yeah i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure
she's manipulating at all
so i'm pretty sure that's what's
happening uh do i think ghost rider will
make an appearance
no dude vision getting drunk off gum
dude that was amazing that was hilarious
i
died laughing when that happened like it
got all hit like it's
his stuff got all gunked up you know and
he's just he's like me in the guys we
had some drinks and he has to go out on
stage drunk doing like a magic show he
was like
look at this guys he's like lifting a
piano and all that kind of stuff that
was that was hilarious
that was hilarious i i love that but um
yeah that was that was that was cool uh
let's see um can i grow my hair out
yeah i probably should um
like i said i think the beekeeper is
advanced idea mechanics
so um the intros in the show were really
good yeah the show is really really cool
so the truman show um
no okay i can almost guarantee we're not
going to see
any x-men in this right we're not going
to see i don't think we're going to see
any x-men in this
it's not as though charles xavier is
going to show up and just be like you've
been going crazy for a while there
uh scarlet witch but now we've got you
back under control so you know
you know and then magic and then leave
that's not gonna happen
[Laughter]
that's not gonna happen
see here's here's a cool theory here's a
cool idea
right and i talk about this in the pop
culture explain video here's here's a
cool thing
sword stands for the sentient world
observation and response department
right where shield monitors earth sword
monitors space
so what's going on that sword is
monitoring the scarlet witch
that's a that's i have a whole theory
about that um
no there's no wonder man we don't see
wonder man at all at least we haven't
yet
um we've not seen wonder man uh
[Music]
let's see do you i think she brings back
quicksilver i think she will
i think quicksilver is going to come
back if you okay if you if you look
closely
at what's going on in the show right now
the the the one division show is a blend
between house of m and one other comic
book story line that marvel published
within the last
three years what do you think that story
line is
the car the person who answers that
question correctly gets a rob core ring
all right who do you who do you think
what do you think the story line is
what do you think that storyline is
oh they recconded the sentient weapon
oh wow sentient website civilian
sentient weapon
observation and response department damn
okay well then the other monitoring
scholarly witch now
wow
huh
uh nope it is not tom king's vision
i mean that's a given you know because
of how the the story looks nope not
avengers standoff
we already said house of m
uh nope not x-men first-class
quicksilver
not secret empire it is not a story that
involves
scarlet witch or vision or any of the
avengers
it is not house of x
uh
nope it's not a secret family
it is not avengers disassembled
uh nope it's not rage of ultron it's not
pleasant pleasantville
pleasantville was good though
it's not avengers versus x-men nope it's
not one more day
it's a it's a story that everybody
overlooks
but if you if you read it it's obvious
what's going on
oh darren williams is close darren
williams is close
everybody's going to go scrolling at
darren williams on that now
nope it's not siege it's not time runs
out
it was in the last three years right so
time runs out was what like five years
ago
four years ago uh it's not different
strokes
uh nope nobody has it so far it's not
native future pass
nope it's not it's not west coast no one
has it so far
i'm killing you nope it was a story that
marvel made within the last
four years or so three years right so
it's within the last three years or so
all the stories you guys are running off
came out like like five or six or seven
or eight years ago
it is not dark hold the book of sin
that's a great guess though
uh nope it's not dark phoenix but that's
close
that's very close
people just hyping up answers
everybody's just trying to get this
answer
uh it is not dark phoenix
okay do you guys want to know the answer
to what i think the other half of the
story is
because it's a blend between house of m
and another story do you guys want to
know what the answer to that is
phoenix force is not a story that's a
character
oh gabriel hb just got it phoenix
resurrection gabriel samuel sent me an
email you get a rob core ring
phoenix resurrection yep that's that's
my vote it's it's a blend between
phoenix resurrection and house of m
i think it's a blend between those two
things right because phoenix
resurrection
was the story where jean grey came back
and initially it was
like they were picking up on these these
little um these little
uh energy signatures that were from that
were coming from like places around the
world
and they eventually honed in on where it
stopped and it was jean grey who had
just
recreated this entire town and like she
resurrected all her friends who died
and like cyclops was back like she
resurrected cyclops and she had
literally just
created this whole little community and
was just living out her everyday life it
was like the dream life she always
wanted
and then the the x-men eventually
confronted her and then all hell broke
loose but
that's exactly what it feels like it
feels like a blend between house of m
and phoenix resurrection like that's
what it feels like
but um but
yeah so uh who was a beekeeper i think
the beekeeper was
uh was was advanced idea mechanics i
know you guys are saying it's sword but
i feel like it was aim
or its aim working for sword right so
um they are doing the vision family
thing but see here's the thing i would
say it would be more in kin with tom
king's vision
if if if it was more vision centric if
it was more vision focused and we got
characters like viv and stuff like that
but we don't really have that right you
don't really have vision's family he
doesn't have like
it's not like a vision wife and a vision
son and a vision daughter you don't
really have that instead it's just
scarlet witch and vision right so
i don't really consider to be very close
to tom king's vision run
it was a great run it was a it was a
great maxi series i mean i loved it it
was just 12 issues of awesome
but uh but no i don't think i don't
think it's it's very close in line with
that at all
um baron strucker yeah
uh why advanced idea mechanics because
it's what aim does and they they they
wear those kind of outfits except aim
outfits are yellow
so um but yeah
you think hydra's definitely involved i
don't think hydra is involved
but we did see a hydra thing right the
the strucker watch
which by the way man that's trucker
watch look clean dude i would love
having that strucker watch
that strucker watch look good as hell i
love the way that thing looked okay what
else do you guys want to know
what else do you guys want to know
uh speed and wiccan yes they are wandas
kids it was never confirmed they were
wandas kids until children's crusade
that's when it was verified
that they were they were officially the
kids of wanda maximoff up until that
point like
like marvel more or less said it but
never really confirmed it
and just by like uh okay rick just by
kind of looking at it you could just
sort of figure out that's that's what
was you know that was the case
you know especially if you read like
what is it young avengers special number
one
different stories like that you figure
out pretty fast that they're kids of
of uh of scarlet witch so oh your ring
came
awesome galactus i'm glad you like it
that's cool
uh what do i think of agnes so far she's
great agnes is great
my question is are they going to keep
agnes in line
with the rest of with with her marvel
counterpart
right because
agatha harkness is a legitimate witch
right she's a legit witch
is what is what the case is with her
she's not really a
she's not like doctor strange where she
where she uses like social supreme
powers or anything like that she does
like the cauldrons and you know
cutting animal like like sacrificing
animals different things like that
um the show's not boring at all show's
amazing
um but she's basically she's she's like
a straight witch and she was the mentor
scarlet witch for a while
so i wonder if they're gonna keep her
more in line with that if she's there to
be like a friendly eye
on wanda to like kind of give whoever's
watching her a true understanding of
what she's actually capable of that kind
of a thing
she's like reporting back to people um
do i think the reason that it was an
actual beekeeper's outfit is because
wanda's reality manipulation well that's
the thing i mean that's possible but
how's a beekeeping suit going to protect
you from reality manipulation
they can't even save you from murder
hornets right like they're not gonna
that's that's not gonna happen
[Laughter]
um let's see that's why
we will see her past because her mind is
trying to put itself back together
by going through time see i don't think
it is i think there's a reason why one
division looks the way it does but that
part i explore on pop culture explain
i'm not going to tell you guys about
that here
but i think there's a reason why
everything looks the way that it does on
one division
um let's see uh did i forget the
password for my twitch account no
no not really it's just a channel to
live stream comments explaining content
but is the channel offline is it not is
it not
uh not running
it should be uh
yeah it's currently live
uh how would doctor strange
oh how would doctor streams tie into all
this um i thought i said how would
doctor strange thee into all this i was
like what
uh i don't know see that's the thing
we're not really given an indication of
when the show happens we don't know when
one division takes place
right we don't know if it takes place um
in like like we don't we don't know if
it takes place
inside like like after the events of
infinity war but before
in the game we don't know if it takes
place after end game um and i don't
think marvel's actually come out and
said when it takes place so i'm not
really sure when it is
uh will magneto be related to wanda no
idea magneto's not in the mcu yet so
there's not really any way for us to
know
unless at the end of the show magneto
shows up and it's like i'm taking my
daughter away from this and like
floats away with her in his arms like
then we'll know
but you know it's it's we don't really
know yet
so um
i don't know if they'll touch on our
real father that's the thing marvel's
marvel's history between like with
scarlet witch and quicksilver being
related to magneto
it's so influx and chaotic and
indistinguishable from from any measure
of sense whatsoever that like there's no
telling what marvel's going to do
so uh predictions will one division
cross over with falcon and the winter
soldier or do i
do or better yet more along the lines of
the style of do i think loki will cross
over
i don't think any of those characters
are going to cross over i think each
individual show is going to be part of
the bigger
mcu but self-contained right in the same
way that like captain america won with
self-contained
or thor one or anything like that like
you you may reference some characters
but they'll just kind of be
kept alone in isolation so uh
oh it takes place in 2023 is that when
it takes place or 2022
2023 uh where are you guys getting that
from because i haven't seen anything
that specifies when the show takes place
uh let's see
you just watch the two episodes
hmm yeah agnes i get the hardness
yeah oh i got something in my eye
i should stop rubbing it but pretty sure
it's an eyelash
um
let's see uh well okay the calendar says
august 23rd 2023
but you can't take that with any real
reality with any real measure of
certainty because
literally the whole show is about her
warping reality right so
you know there's no real way to know if
it's accurate or not
so i mean we can assume that it is but
we don't really know for certain
in a show where nothing is certain i
certainly wouldn't trust the calendar
if that's what you got you know that's
that's kind of what i'm saying here
um let's see
uh yeah the radio broadcast jimmy wu
yeah that was nuts wanda wanda who's
doing this to you
um let's see
i mean they did do a five year time skip
and end game but again like we don't
know if it takes place during that five
year time skip
that's one of the things to keep in mind
guys is is the mcu has historically well
not historically but they have done
things
out of order in the past right so we
like there's unless they come out and
explicitly tell us or unless like
she comes out into the real world it's
like what year is it really and it's
like it's this year or something like
that then we'll know but
you know i wouldn't really set a whole
lot of store by by a calendar
[Laughter]
um let's see uh do i expect a reversal
of the
no more mutants uh i mean it was
reversed a long time ago
so so what i mean when you when you say
like a reversal do you mean like
like no more superheroes or like no more
avengers
is is that what you're talking about
i mean but that's that's the thing like
i mean yeah wanda was snapped but like
is this taking place in seoul world i
mean that's that's
that's what we don't have an answer to
right that's that's where things are not
given to us i mean
thanos appeared in soul world but it was
just this great big huge blink
bleak emptiness and just void that went
on for eternity
so i don't i don't know it could be
totally different i mean we know with
for example from the old adam warlock
comics the soul world looks different to
different people
so it kind of depends um
let's see no more multiverse oh no i
don't think we'll get anything like that
monica rambo was cool mommy that that
that what is it uh
what is her name it starts with a g i
always forget i keep wanting to say
uh um
oh my god um
it's not galadrie i keep wanting to say
galadria that was from lord of the rings
um it's not jordina
geraldine that's what it is geraldine
yeah what a strange name
um but yeah geraldine so yeah that's
definitely
um that's definitely monica rambo
i mean it's the same actress
[Laughter]
so that's that's definitely monica rambo
so
um yeah the real question is what's she
doing there
right that's the real question because
here's here's the thing like if it was
all kinds of if it was scarlet witch
popped off altered reality
sword responded they sent in geraldine
and then she was a birthday sent in
monica she was immediately taken over
alongside everybody else and kind of
her mind was basically dominated but it
could be that she's just there as a spy
right because that's that's my thought
that like geraldine i get the harkness
um that they're basically there and just
monitoring her
right like they're there as effectively
spies monitoring her and just
blending in alongside everybody else uh
and just keeping an eye on what's going
on and then in turn um
you know it once everything goes back to
normal then of course you know they'll
they'll reveal who they really are but
uh that's kind of my thought at that
moment
right just kind of on top of my head but
um
that's your aunt's name
uh let's see she might have joined sword
yeah i wouldn't be surprised if she did
right if she joined sword because of um
oh cool okay yeah if she joined sword
because of
uh because of captain marvel of carol
danvers right karen
carol danvers basically becomes the head
of sword uh like she does in the comics
the well technically it's the alpha
flight protocols is what
carol danvers is in charge of um and
then monica rambo joins up because of
carol danvers that would not surprise me
so um could cathode be a villain i think
a throne is more likely to be a villain
than scarlet witch's
because she he's basically scarlet
witch's arch nemesis that you almost
never see
so like i think they've only ever like
you know like
duked it out for lack of a better word
you've never really seen a fight between
scarlet witch and cathode
um but they they've never really done
that for a long time so
um agatha seems to enjoy wanda's
confusion see i don't think wada's
confused
i think she knows exactly what's going
on because she did it so
uh josh s rob it's been three years and
100 plus comments what happened with the
reed richards
that captures doctor doom toward the end
of
my hickman fantastic four video oh i
don't remember it's been so long
uh i guess i need to go back and and
reread that and find out
um you don't know how they're gonna
explain me i mean bringing mutants in
will be pretty simple
be pretty easy to do uh vision is so
yeah
i love vision he's hilarious i love i
love vision in there
uh he's amazing
um it's it's cool so uh
vision's boss is wanda's dad
you really think so
um you really believe that that
vision's boss is wanda's dad i mean if
that were the case though you'd think
he'd have a more prominent role
yeah when carter uses the dark hold um
now i see when you're talking about him
possessing wanda that was during the
events of secret empire
they do have some flashback stories in
marvel where they basically explain how
he touched wanda and gave her a portion
of his power
so she could be an avatar that he could
take over one day but
um
i don't think jack of hearts is is gonna
be the same kind of jack of hearts that
we're familiar with the guy who explodes
uh i don't think it'll be exactly like
that
um it's for the children
do we know how long the show is the show
is
technically four and a half hours long
but it's nine 30-minute installments
um which honestly given the way the show
looks is a perfect amount of time
that's the perfect time to do it uh
let's see you love the super dark scene
with uh when mr heart chokes yeah
i mean that's the thing though i don't i
mean see like that was the moment right
there
when i realized well there were there
were a couple moments but there were
there was a moment right there when i
realized
okay like they know exactly what like
wanda knows exactly what she's doing
like this all exists because she wants
it to
right like when when mr hart's choking
and his and like
his wife's like like uh what is it his
wife saying like stop it or like do
something or something like that
and uh and she says like vision like
like help me and like vision pulls the
gun out or pulls the food out of his
throat
um that's when i was kind of like okay
like i'm pretty sure
i know exactly what's going on it's like
like yeah it's like five minutes of
credits
so um that's how shows were back then
too i think
but um or how shows are now anyway like
it's one of the funny things i realized
like myself from mariah we've got
youtube tv
and we were watching law and order last
night and we realized that sundance tv
actually speeds up the intros of the
shows and speeds up
segments of the shows so they can cram
in more advertising
more more uh ad space right which is
kind of like damn yeah stop it that's
what i thought it was
so i mean i feel like i felt like when
she said one like one when she said stop
it she was talking to wanda
and then two like it was do something
about him right like don't let him die
so um yeah that's trucker watch
commercial was clean man like i want to
struck her watch now
like i want one of those watchers you
know like
like struck her watches you know he'll
make time for you
yeah the commercials represent the
events of the yeah that's that's one of
the first things i picked up on
is the commercials represent the
traumatic moments in her life and i
think that's going to continue on
right like i think it's going to
continue on in that trend like you're
going to see commerce like all the
commercials are going to represent like
the traumatic moments of wanda's life
so um
do i think the series is going to
introduce the mutants into the mcu no i
don't think it's going to do that
i do not believe this series is going to
introduce mutants to the mcu
could ultron return possibly but i don't
think he will at least not for a long
time
um why didn't they make it a one-hour
episode kind of series because honestly
given the way the series is done
one hour would have stretched on too
long if one of these episodes was an
hour long i probably would have lost
interest about 45 minutes into it
you know about over halfway through i
think half an hour is a perfect amount
of time they're more like 25 minutes but
i feel like that's a perfect amount of
time
for each episode so um
let's see uh hold on
uh grim reaper's helmet shows up
inside the floor in the animated intro
what i totally miss that
does it really
you think juan is going to say more
people like me
damn she could
and that would bring back mutants i also
think um the moment where mr hart is
looking at everything going on he's like
all this chaos going on here
i think that's a reference to wanda
using chaos magic
i think it's like a nod i don't think
it's i don't think it matters or
anything i don't have any significance
but i think it's a nice little nod
so damn
um because here's the thing i always
skip over intros
i never pay attention to intros so
you're telling me i need to go back and
watch the intros is what you're saying
um let's see
you think mr hart is agatha's parents
and everyone
stuck inside is either from sword or
people who've
wronged agatha and agatha is using wanda
to hurt them
uh i don't think agatha's there is a bad
guy
i think agatha is there as like somebody
to monitor
scarlet witch or keep an eye on her or
something like that
um let's see you think uh oh yeah we
already read that okay what role does mo
the mind stone play here does it control
wanda well that's that's kind of the
kicker is the mind stone as it operates
in the mcu is different from the comics
in the mcu it's a technology it's a
technological device it's basically a
super advanced ai
so it doesn't really seem to work in the
same capacity that like it can dominate
the minds of all sentient beings in the
universe
it doesn't really seem to work that way
um maybe it does but we have not seen it
work that way
the only way we've seen the mind stone
work is one when it was used by vision
to basically give him sentience and
allow him to exist
in a more human form and then two when
thanos used it to complete the infinity
gauntlet and that was it that was the
only real extent that we got to it
um okay uh rob sword tried to infiltrate
her bubble reality without being noticed
hence the beekeeper outfit
they're currently monitoring it from
outside and are trying to communicate
with her
yeah i think that's what's cool i think
it's jimmy woo that's chiming in because
we got the radio broadcast
so that much i'm pretty sure about um
do i think the scarlet witch has already
had a mental breakdown or do i think
that has yet to come i think she's in
the midst of it i think she's in the
middle of having it
uh rob can you explain the hydra watch
being stuck on 242 maybe it stands for
avengers number 242
vision gets a new body and the beyonder
is introduced leading to secret wars
that's the the prevailing theory that
i've heard from people
like i've seen that all over the
internet right that it's high that
it ties directly into that and that it
has something to do with like the
beyonder
or something along those events um
honestly i think it's a little
too soon to start talking about secret
wars
i know it's something the mcu wants to
do and i know it's something that the
the um the russos have have said they
wanted to do
but i feel like it's a little too soon
to start talking about the idea of
um the idea of secret wars
uh let's see do i think mephisto will
try to take wanda's children and use
them to his liking
like in the comics i don't think i don't
think that'll happen
um this could be okay yeah okay so you
guys are coming up with theories
i want to know your theories right give
me your theories i want to know what
your theories are
this could be crazy but your theory is
that someone maybe mephisto is doing
this to her
to get her kids and that's why the town
is saying
for the children over and over again
agnes talks about
the devil uh maybe
i mean what would be the benefit though
because the whole reason behind
mephisto's actions with regards to the
kids in the comics is that
they were pieces of his soul so he was
just taking back pieces of his soul
but unless unless wanda took pieces of
the devil's soul
and then you know made her made her kids
out of it but
i don't know i mean the house changed
yeah i think she i think wada was also
pregnant towards at the end of the
episode like she looked like she was
pregnant
um ultron's voice is credited in the
cast and crew
i mean i don't know if it's like a
flashback or something that's used i
know james spader was the one but it
might also be something else
in terms of like a future mention or
something along those lines
um oh i think she'll bring back uh
bring back quicksilver i think that's
gonna happen uh
let's see if she can create objects and
how to uh and how powerful
can these objects become uh i don't know
i mean there's there's no indication
that there's any limit
to what she can do which is probably why
she's being monitored
um vision is being used to create the
alternate reality as a super computer
i mean i'd be kind of disappointed if
that was i mean not to insult your
theory but i'd be kind of disappointed
that was the
the part your theory is the entire town
are villains and superheroes
everyone that would be kind of cool so
like uh like um
avengers standoff basically uh
let's see you think aim is doing
something
isn't aim symbolize as a beehive yeah so
take that pair the hexagon into the
intro and outro
and then the bee keeper and that appears
uh in the second maybe they are testing
her
maybe like i said i think the beekeepers
advance idea mechanics i've been saying
that like i feel like the beekeeper is
aim
right i mean the only the only
difference between an aim agent and the
beekeeper
is that the bee keeper's outfits white
instead of yellow
right but um yeah do i think we'll see
the mini angled ones in doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness i hope so
even if only for a moment i really hope
we get to see the mini angled ones
because they were cool
um the mailman's galactus
[Laughter]
pew pew pew don't shoot me i'm just the
messenger
i'm just a destroyer of worlds
[Laughter]
oh man um
you want hyperion to show up in the end
uh
yeah okay so i guess that is a really
good question right somebody you know um
uh
jason jason hans just asked this so so i
guess you know let's let's go ahead and
start wrapping this up right because i
do want to get out to that comic book
shop before they before they start to
shut down
so here's a question that i want to ask
you guys overall the first two episodes
of
of one division did you like it
right because the cool thing about only
getting two episodes so far
um is that we basically get to
just fan theory over everything until
stuff starts to become solidified
and we actually know definitively what's
going on we just get to really get to
nerd out and just fan theory over stuff
um so yeah like like what do you guys
you know did you guys enjoy the show i
think it's probably one of the coolest
things did you guys
enjoy wanda vision what were your
thoughts on it did you like it did you
hate it did you find it boring
you know what what are your what are
your thoughts i thought it was meh
you loved it ralph was mephisto
they were so good uh you enjoyed them
you liked it
it was different for sure but it was
cool yeah i agree with that
it left you you liked it but it left you
wanting more yeah that's kind of how i
felt i really want to see more episodes
uh
seven out of ten so far hmm it was
different
it's a breath of fresh air coming from
marvel yeah it is because you can set
your clock
you can set your watch by marvel movies
right so it is a great breath of fresh
air
so uh the show is so good yeah i'm
definitely
i'm definitely so are you guys excited
for the next episode for episode three
are you guys excited for that because
you guys realize we have to wait a week
before we get to see the next episode
are you guys excited for it
because i am i'm very excited for it
agnes husband is mephisto that would be
a crazy plot twist
like is agatha and mephisto fighting
over scarlet witch that would be a
crazy plot twist
the beekeepers candyman
be my victim
the tension's great very nice pacing has
a great vibe to it it does have a great
vibe to it
uh
uh no the the all the episodes that come
out from here on out are just the the
one the single episodes
so it'll just be 30 minutes next week 30
minutes after that 30 minutes after that
so on and so forth
so this the this week was just the first
and second episode
you're super stoked for the series yeah
oh yeah we'll definitely we'll probably
end up doing this for for each of the
episodes we'll probably end up doing
this for for each of the episodes that
come out
because i'll be honest man here's here's
one of the things about being a youtuber
right
making videos is fun and it's enjoyable
um
but i like talking to you guys man like
i like comparing theories you know
comparing like
what i think is going on how i think
things are happening and like like
things that i've missed or things that i
got wrong
and you guys being like no no it's
actually this like like the grim
reaper's helmet
i never knew that was in the intro like
i love talking to you like i love
nerding out with you guys over stuff
like this so
yeah no i mean stuff like this is fun
like this i love i love doing this
so do you guys want me to do this again
next week do you guys do you guys
want to do this again next week
i mean if you guys do let me know just
say yeah
is full killer finally back i don't know
i never cared about deadpool's ancillary
team uh
more streams uh
it would be funny if the beekeeper was
mephisto would be a weird reason for him
to show up
so yes yeah this is great
for the children like hell yeah
[Laughter]
oh man
um but yeah okay cool yeah you guys
really seem to dig it so
all right awesome i mean that's the
thing not every video that i make needs
to be one that just racks up tons of
views right i just
i just like hanging out and talking to
you guys right just like talking to my
fans
talking to my fans and nerding out and
talking about comic books and stuffs
uh yeah okay guys well thank you guys
for coming out um this has been
awesome it's been an absolute blast uh
but yeah thanks for coming out guys
i'm gonna go ahead and in this stream
i'm gonna head to the comic book store
grab some or at least go check out the
new comic book store anyway
um do some poking around and and get a
feel for what all they have going on
and then yeah uh i guess i will catch
you all later
peace